it's okay we got cool air and that's
what really matters
all right who's on you now who's on you
now come on guys I'm on us yeah we got
three eyes on us three three eyes on me
you know like a 2-pack back love that
2-pack grass out grass album we don't
need to drink it all we're drunk already
in life hey guys hey hey hey girl hey
dirty birdie Damon happy Valentine this
single is a printable you're letting
them view the Brendan V happy
Valentine's Day Ben Murphy it's 3:00 in
the morning bet you're jerking it what -
Borat coax it okay what's going on
Nintendo's Zilla any romance movie that
has blood gore and violence is my
favorite ooh we're doing people charming
in here it's a day oh yes well I like to
sweep so guys guys spread the word
spread the lid because it's Valentine's
Day this isn't the last day in my
apartment and this is a poster you guys
everything to see it's already blocked
by a light this is really cool painting
Mossad Barnard today we're gonna play a
little game everyone who donates 1,200
bars every 1,200 bars every 1,200 bars I
will take a shot at her John's not a
[ __ ] he will take a shot with me two of
one of these two and vodka or Jack
Daniels and every ten thousand bars Greg
and I will kiss okay we're really gonna
do that
that's up to you oh we gotta get a
little more sure I'll forget to do that
the singles day with John and Greg on
Valentine's Day and what are we doing
we're talking to a bunch of strangers
online about our favorite romantic films
ever do so like I said every 1,200 bars
John and I will take a shot I have
anxious to drink so
you guys start donating this is a little
experiment bro to get drunk it takes at
least four shot that we need at least
6,800 bars to get you're up how many
people are in this audience
let's see before we before we kick off
our our talk let's check you the strike
you tube you know people are chimed in
there and of course for those who donate
you get a special shout out as we toss a
drink back oh yeah oh yeah we'll say
your name out loud we even call you dead
we ready got one dislike on YouTube whoo
that guy's a loyal subscriber hey man
either way you're talking about us
haters gonna hate
let's go oh we got 50 bars oh we're
almost at 1,200 bars there yeah guys
thank you thank you thank you Ben Murphy
69 all right let's kick off our talk
slay me daddy so we don't really have
like a top ten list here we just have
like some favorite romantic films that
we'd like to talk with you guys about
writing down the stuff we'll share with
you guys some of these some of these
things so John I'll kick off this list
of my favorite rom-com or romantic films
my first one would have to be hey I need
a stars here you know stars here yeah my
favorite my I guess one of my favorite
my favorite romantic comedy is probably
when Harry Met Sally you know I really
meant bullying yo people on YouTube if
you really want to interact you're gonna
have to come over to you now that's a
you now tip that I just received that
popped up on our screen yeah guys come
on over join us join us you want a you
know my favorite one would have to be
would Harry Met Sally have you seen one
Harry Met Sally I have not gone all the
way through John doesn't like romantic
films he doesn't believe in a romance I
just have a
finalizing our cystic prick like that I
am When Harry Met Sally if you guys
haven't seen it it's about these guys
harry and Sally who've been best friends
for like 10 years and then they sleep
together one day and start falling in
love with each other oh man and I can
tell you I have been there before really
oh yeah yeah I've definitely been there
in love or in love with the best
freshmen in and it's very relatable and
at the time in my life I thought it was
super romantic now when I look back on
it I think it's rather heartbreaking in
a shallow film for reminding me of my
devastation bastards
the whole relationship yeah my opinion
just changed romance yeah the movies
okay love this is a sham well I think
would happen in Harry Met Sally it was
one of those rare rom-coms that felt
like real characters okay like these
were real people just really interacted
I think that's why it's a rom-com that
really stands the test of time it seems
like people love them yeah people really
love their on-screen relationship them
together like feeling that's tight under
the actors just as much as you know the
story like there's an iconic image to
cover yeah yeah do you guys like When
Harry Met Sally it's kind of hard to
have a back and forth when only one of
us has seen them I'm sorry man hey
Brendon V give us 515 bars dude Brendon
baby wants to see us tell you wanna see
us take a drink we're almost up to 1200
mark every 1,200 it'll be a cumulative
so you guys can work together on this
one doesn't have to be one large 1,200
bar donation there's a guy called froggy
the Frog on YouTube who was just throw
it down Madame oh geez so uh I noticed
you you know what we were gonna talk our
favorite rom-coms
there's some people who want to guess
with us I think I might we might spend
some time with them man share the love
John what's one of your favorite
rom-coms or romantic films my one of my
favorite romantic film is Gregory I
would have to say is before sunrise is
that the one with the Ethan Hawke Ethan
Hawke and Julie Delpy the the Richard
Linklater friends really all three but
especially the first
the second one okay um they're all great
but those are just love those films so
much like their they have one of those
very natural and very you know real
on-screen relationships like you fall in
love with the both of them over the
course of that movie and it's you know
it's kind of a different type of film
cuz the whole thing is just a
conversation and yours watching this
night unfold between two people it's
it's [ __ ] great well what's one of
the things that what do we look for when
we watch a romantic film um well I guess
I guess the most sort of basic thing is
like you want to see two people who
really have a spark you know ajik that
makes us feel that magic to that sort of
flush that comes with you know getting
feelings for somebody I understand that
and you know I thought leads me to my
next film then which is Notting Hill
have you seen this one damn it Sean
naughty naughty rail [ __ ] ah do Brenda
be thanks for the like hey we got some
more bars from Ben Murphy 50 more bars a
hundred plus 500s 600 650 see twenty
hundred twenty more bars to go wow you a
buy a two hundred for fans of this
broadcast Notting Hill is one of the
best romantic comedies of all time
because I think it plays on every
everyone's random fantasy of celebrity
you notice about no Hugh Grant is this
bookstore owner in London who one day
meets this famous ass movie star played
by Julia Roberts okay and they end up
half developing a romantic relationship
he's just this normal dude who starts
getting involved with this superstar and
she's kind of weird a little closed off
because she doesn't really trust the
public and everything like that and I
that was a movie where I fell in love
with him like when they first kiss a
smile comes to my face that's a rare
movie that makes me believe in love and
I cry a corny cheesy [ __ ] yeah is every
finale of any great romantic movie has
to be in front of a big audience worse
they profess their love in some way look
at any romantic comedy not your sunset
movies in summer doesn't like but look
at any romantic romantic comedy yeah
to comedy you think of any Sandler
romantic comedy or or even love actually
there's always like they end up
confessing with a lot of people watching
them this is an awkward situation but
this is how real and were [ __ ] is love
that we're gonna have to say in front of
all these people worth it for love yeah
love is the battlefield you guys got a
watch you guys got a watch Notting Hill
for sure there's I think there's one
movie that we've both seen what my
favorite romantic movie is well I I
guess sort of a melancholy romantic
movie but I really adored her her is a
great wealth Joaquin Phoenix
and the voice of Scarlett Johansson yeah
that was a great yeah that was another
that's a rare rock romantic film yeah
yeah like it has that I mean Spike Jones
brings that that magic that awesome
level of grounded fantasy yeah yeah yeah
and now and I thought of also in this
little I I guess I pick like sad
romantic movies because I also thought
of eternal sunshine eternal sunshine but
you haven't seen that I have seen it I
just need to I really need to see it
again is like I don't know such as one
of my favorite movies of all time people
I love Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind that's me you gave me a movie for
my birthday I wish I could do that with
every girl I've met eternal sunshine
erase them and they say grace
crazy [ __ ] is out of my mind yeah it's
miss so many bad [ __ ] so many bad
[ __ ] I need to say hi to the camera
Nina come here I mean I'm actually
popping in from the camera what's with
this shy closed-off add to you have
today some of the dishwasher mm-hmm
just say hi hey guys Anita's here you
guys know need us hi dear we're not
lying all right let's see what some hey
two Avengers thanks for the bars by the
way yeah you know we're gonna take shots
every time you should join the game you
were tardy a dick he brought up a movie
friends-with-benefits you guys ever seen
that with Ryan Reynolds no no that's
where he says just friends know your
movies friends and benefits
I'm supposed to win that Chevrolet gonna
be a showdown right yes yeah that one's
really funny yeah we have to wait till
12 wonderful you can donate man I need I
could drink you're not subject to the
rules of the yeah yes go ahead drink
Anita drink and he is an alcoholic she's
a struggling alcoholic she gets rageful
friends friends with benefits is one of
the film that like out of all like you
know the great friend of Justin
Timberlake assisted his filmography is
very late occasionally tunes in like a
great performance that's my favorite one
he's ever done I feel like he's very
natural as comedic timing is completely
on par is chemistry with Mila Kunis is
awesome it's more of a realistic
romantic comedy than we're used to
getting these days okay I think it's
another one as a big finale where a
bunch of people who see them talk to
each other yeah I saw the other one I
saw no strings I saw no strings attached
tails I've never had a friends with
benefit I've kind of but not like this
stated way Jews are you an alcoholic
this is an intervention
Oh potato Canton potato God's 9,000
asked about hitch have you seen hitch
ah hitch some of it I think some of it
yeah sorry I just like some films no -
well dude it's because you don't believe
in love
I don't Bob I'm like this [ __ ] man he's
so great getting relationships together
we can't do it you know well you know
what I feel like we should bring up what
a film the two Avengers are you 2015 ng
has just brought up it's called la la
bland people oh yeah la la la was the
best movie of 2016 in my personal
opinion I don't give a [ __ ] but I need
these [ __ ] on the internet come out
hood super rude [ __ ] you it's gonna
happen it is good
best movie of 2016
you cut boom on the record that's gonna
go on the DVD go ahead someone in this
comment box challenge me challenge me
I'll fight you I'm not even I've met a
single drink yet I'll fight you to the
death beer okay all right - Xavier VR
age 35 bars thanks my friend Ben Murphy
50 potato God 50 Brendan be 600 we got
1200 yes
jump what about that calculator let me
get my calc all right
hit me with them numbs okay all right
645 645 + 50 + 50 + 35 35 plus 15 plus
15 equals 795 Oh 420 more bars to go we
got it
what are these likes do you know they
boost our disability and [ __ ] oh really
yeah 12 Frederick it's Valentine's Day
and apparently most of our subscribers
are not a bunch of lonely people at the
computer which is surprising that's why
there's not more than 60 people here and
plus we very barely go on are you now
account 20 is actually a lot of people
for us to be in this chat everyone's got
up to 40 people yeah that was crazy okay
oh whoa whoa
you don't forget to do we're gonna do
we're gonna guess someone oh [ __ ] oh yes
we're gonna make sin of God we're gonna
guess you're a few for a couple minutes
guest you so not gonna take up all our
time guess the [ __ ] out of you you
better you better answer a potato go go
gooo God oh you didn't answer
come on potato I will fight three
Avengers oh wait potato got you there
put eights
I don't think you know we're staring at
he's about to show us his dick potato
God potato God come in potato God come
into your radar send your lonely
Valentine's Day with us
oh he laughing I think I hurt his
feelings a little bit he was going to
show you his dick then you called him
out so he's like nah performance anxiety
Anita who's your Valentine myself
Anita is gonna pleasure herself tonight
self-love is the best masturbation game
alleviates the frustration game kind of
I learned about this thing the other day
yeah
let me look up the word it's when you
come but you're sad yeah Cletus know
when I come I get sad I just I put it on
Google it's a real thing I read about it
why do we is post-coitus or something
like quite a sentence after step yes
whatever
what's coitus there's an actual
condition for it and I haven't guys
post-coital sad every time I could get
Jack you late Oh Anita doesn't ever
watch the real rejects she doesn't even
like the video she's in so don't worry
about her you know what [ __ ] this I
think we set the bar a little too high
over 1200 yeah 1200 for a shot I just
want a drink I don't even give a [ __ ]
about the bars right yeah you know what
we created the rules change the rules
rules
John what someone on YouTube saying
what's that yeah let's just answer some
questions we're just gonna change
everything up check it out alright
someone said Cooper man just now jerk
each other off with mayonnaise is
something somebody's on YouTube that's
creative
I just masturbate it's so damn hard with
the free pornhub premium somebody says
wow someone asked how we're doing we're
doing well we're doing well someone has
requested help so jump on that you know
guys I'll share with you guys a
Valentine
today's story there's a place called
macelli's it's this Italian restaurant
where the waiters sing the waiters sing
any of cheers to your gosh dear God God
God
so macelli's there's this this booth
they call the Valentine's Day booth let
me paint you a picture of this
restaurant it's this really fancy
Italian restaurant with waiters that are
singing and everything is super decked
out like mimicking Italy and then at the
top there's no second floor but there's
a sort of second floor it's this booth
that oversees the whole restaurant you
were the spotlight if you have this
booth and it cost money you got a
reserve at months in advance and one
time I was able to get that through yeah
smooth robbers video with wine I was too
full to get laid that night that's a
good good Valentine's Day rather be
fooled and sexually you're satisfied
that's just the way I operate Jeff the
killer one one five hey John how's your
Valentine's Day gone
do you know pretty day like it's been
like most days lately so that's cool
John never talked about your romantic
life I know look if there's one thing I
can tell you your reputation just
automatically goes up when you reveal
your personal life oh yeah you know cuz
you seem more like a human and people
are likely to accept you and not judge
me yes like one time I put up this fake
video called Greg Alba where I was
crying
they're all fake Spears and everyone
believed the hoax the whole time yeah it
was convincing I need the phone yeah my
condo we're in a real relationship that
was not the case yeah like all the hosts
I'm gay I've never even felt a woman
this is a transgender really
that's cool she's got a huge [ __ ]
52 people are watching on YouTube
hey ah someone said Long Island sucks oh
who said that who said that it's someone
on YouTube 8 cooks who ako sa Kos ok
little movie fights tell me why it sucks
I'll get back to you mm-hmm
tell me why it sucks need any more
alcohol guys I don't need a girl on
Valentine's Day
I got you [ __ ] who the hell is
here alone on Valentine's Day on their
computer you guys and us I don't need a
woman I don't need intimacy I don't need
a connection companionship of any kind I
just need you guys it's a big old
Spanish galleon join the join the throng
hey dirty birdie Damon wants you to be
his Valentine I'll be your Valentine I
want you to be my Valentine I'll be your
Valentine
what's the most romantic thing a guys
ever done for you Anita for me oh jeez
shave you hold out she's funny she's
funny
I'm glad everybody's romantic I'm glad
everyone thinks for boning yeah yeah we
are one day we'll release a sex tape sex
tape probably so penetrating me with
your strap balls I wrote there are a lot
of places to do that on the Internet I
mean you guys can make a solid side ie
you mean the John Brennan oh yeah
believed I was gay for a second did he
guys listen I had my gay experiments
there behind me now behind me
see what I did there but no I mean I'm
just not that attractive guys even like
really good-looking guys anything are
you kidding why I just get jealous Ryan
Gosling doesn't count he's a movie star
movie stars
that's true I'm talking about like when
I go to the gym and I'm in the locker
room and there's a do with an 8 pack
with his dick out I'm never like oh yeah
yeah there's plenty make you do it
especially older dudes walk around like
a full flap just like you know put their
legs up on the bench like right next to
your head yeah yeah Jay this is this
everyone's just asking about you yeah
she's Francis the truth she's friends
with Tyrone Magnus as you guys know
Tyrone Magnus there's a fraud who fakes
all of his reactions
he's never reacted to anything that he
hasn't already seen in real life Tyrone
is a liar or like every time Tyrone
watches a video he's already seen it
like three times is he kinds all his
movements it's very fake it's very
altered guys you can tell him I said
this every single motion of that man's
face predetermined cheers okay well I'm
gonna get a shot glass then yes there
are no more did you masturbate today me
no everyone all right ask them all the
right questions yeah did you guys
masturbate are you masturbating right
now we're gonna try to connect to
Avengers you know it's funny only guys
are on this livestream
hey yo what's up dude what up dude honey
what's the huh
do you look like hispanic harry potter
man hey hey I got something for you
Oh take that Lotus or whatever your name
is I'm an [ __ ] on YouTube said that
it sucks I know I saw it I saw it four
times
nice I've only seen it three times
you're one more than me my friend
where are you are you laughs I'm from
Illinois you're out there right now yes
what time is it over there
it is almost 9:30 9:30 you're not out on
a date right now no why would I
how old are you I'm 18 18 okay have you
been to a strip club yet nope Wow
stripped yet you don't know John's ever
been to a strip club
[Music]
Wow you've been to a bar what our girls
in Chicago like I don't live in Chicago
where's Illinois Chicago is in Illinois
but I live in a different part of
Illinois that's right I got Chicago is a
city state yeah sorry sorry thank god
this isn't live I look like a real idiot
la-la-land in IMAX you saw it on IMAX
yes was it amazing I missed it on IMAX I
really wanted to go it's much better is
it someone convinced me not to do it I
was but someone convinced me that oh
it's such an old time he kind of feel
the movie you don't want to go on IMAX
but I should have listened to my
instincts and just done it myself no
yeah it's much better so you're into
film huh yes yes what are you studying
writing directing um I don't I don't
know well what are your favorite kind of
films any any ones that entertain me
really that's a very general answer so
what can i film
reliably interesting yeah we're gonna
pull teeth on you man
action comedy okay alright there you
seen white chicks we've seen Hot Fuzz of
course I've seen Hot Fuzz I have that
whole trilogy hell yeah but have you
seen white chicks have you I've seen it
i I I don't get I don't get the big deal
about it it really comes together on the
fifth time give it five times you you
really start to see how the pieces
connect is actually quite brilliant it's
a metaphor have you seen a little man
it's good I'm just naming the greats
right now do you little man I saw a
piece of that on TV it was it was
Wayne's tacular have you seen scary
movie - [ __ ] the first one
my number one favorite comedy of all
time is Blazing Saddles did you let you
like know much yes yes my top two
favorite comedies of all time is Mel
Brooks films okay what's the other one
Young Frankenstein it's young yeah yeah
there you go
I thought he was gonna say something
like it hot or silent movie that was a
bad joke I'm sorry for letting you down
silent movie what's you what's your name
by the way it's Mitchell Mitchell
Mitchell Mitchell Mitchell is exposing
its neck that's a that's a sign of
vulnerability
I like your chain trust us if you were
here now
I would not flinch our trust is strong
well dude we got a we got to give back
to the chat room now but hey it was nice
talking with you thanks for stopping by
tune in next week where we saved the
city from the evil mayor guys guys I
don't know if you know this but robes
stuck rotated a thousand bars shot my
n-word someone give me a shot
please to this man just goes to road
store oh we're running low on vodka you
make quick work of that
quick work is six months in the progress
there's barely anything in here fine you
guys go ahead I'm having browsing oh are
you about to do what I think you're
about javi you're vrh says that's not
gonna go down with Tyrone is not even
black and that's shrimp how did he know
he's a fraud Tyrone's from Japan it's
all blackface what do you mean what am I
allowed to do switch up the alcohol is
that bad
well it's just gonna be gross really
what you're talking about all alcohol
tastes gross some people develop a roof
I'd see a pattern ones that we're taking
shots guys it sucks about some romantic
comedies for 10 more minutes Natural
Born Killers that's not a romance oh my
god it's so romantic true romance is
more like it all right guys I am last
year so that right hey hey sure Scott
man Patricia Arquette Patrice O'Neal
that's the best Christian Slater movie
name one better one
Supermax is the best one that and broken
air stops a missile from John Travolta
what about what's that movie where he
runs the pirate radio station make it
louder you know it's a great room you
know this one Sandler movie that always
gets to me and I cry at the guy
sometimes a Adam Sandler movie 50 first
with a ridiculous ending that I cry at
the end of every time and that is what
John said soccer just testing oh really
I would have guessed so hurt is that not
the way to cry that [ __ ] but 50 first
dates really gets me have you seen it
yeah oh you finally talk about because I
like together in the theater you see
fifty first [ __ ] yeah guys this guy's
just loves this girl so much he has
invested this life long journey where
every night or morning before she wakes
up he has to expand whatever video he's
made for her and now with the editing
systems of things like iMovie and stuff
it'll be way easier to keep up with a
semi a chick
yeah he just started luck 50 version a
doesn't make a great vlogs here it would
be and I don't know just so he just
loves her so much that he's just willing
to do that for her and like it's so
sweet when she wakes up she doesn't that
ending scene she wakes up she doesn't
remember anything with it she sees the
life that she's made with him the real
Dylan gamer took those thousand bars
shot shot
outside mr. world
I forget how the lyrics go men cheese
roaster rom-com action kind of like true
wise hey that's a good one shrew lies is
a really good one sure life is really
good at that's Marvel's best movie you
know what romantic comedy I love that I
grew up with its clueless
you grew up on clueless huh hell yeah I
grew up on clueless anyway where's your
drink
I saw the [ __ ] out of that movie when I
was young okay who's gonna be our DD I
guess that's me no you don't have to do
that John will be a bummer on his phone
taking care of people stressed out we've
been there we're gonna go to spice in
the Hollywood if anyone if you guys live
in LA going to spice tonight Hollywood
and Highland our friend Brandon yeah I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get so much sexual
nothing to Liza's of really that's a
really fun that we saw I know we can I
know John and I are normally great going
into this rise drive is actually a super
romantic if you look at the film of
Drive yeah yeah if you look at the film
of Drive it's a romantic film at its
heart this man who can't be with this
woman decides to help out her ex-husband
convict in order to like help them have
a better life and she's like all I want
you to do is just not mention it to your
wife like that's his only request is
like just don't mention this to your
wife as he wants her to be happy
well things go wrong and the monster
comes out of him when that elevator
scene when he smashes that [ __ ] head
in because of the fact that this man was
gonna kill the woman he loves and that's
what I would do to anyone who hurt the
woman I loved I'm not in love with
anyone right now so I I won't do that to
a
okay good to know mm-hmm but if like I
was getting a massage from a guy and
then he touched my dick without my
consent I'd smash his head in
if it was a girl I wouldn't isn't that
weird it just makes me sound homophobic
that's weird how your guys respond that
way I must resort to violence in this I
need to take my shot way to that man who
donated Oh Princess Bride guys Princess
Bride
pretty romantic very like as you wish
master sleep okay we're not forgetting
sarah marshall forgetting sarah marshall
a good one you might not think romantic
comedy when you first hear forgetting
sarah marshall it's an ultra Mantic
because it starts off about a breakup
which leads to him [ __ ] you know but I
feel like in real life it probably
wasn't the healthiest thing of them
getting together him and Mila Kunis know
like he's on this trip he's recently
broken up sure he's like [ __ ] like 12
other woman according to the film he's
like a montage of him boning a bunch of
people know about Jason Segel wrote that
role that means Jason Segel believes
that he's capable of being a man who
broke up taking bone density broken
today this shows dignity must be
competent he must be as a big
decent-sized pain yeah is a big dick
yeah Forgetting Sarah Marshall what
about um yeah you like that bad with
high action where do Brennan be slowly
doting in more and more bars
you're a good man my friend what about
some like genre romances oh you mean
like Titanic yeah that's a timeless love
story
oh yeah it's I tannic is that's a great
film man I saw it twice in the theaters
I cried both times way in the future
you know people give that whole I got to
defend that movie okay you know when she
goes I'll never let go Jack
yeah yeah no no no no [ __ ] that
all right it was it was about
emotionally not like everyone gives a
[ __ ] yeah physically she let him go she
didn't want to share the door that is
the see you guys [ __ ] what they call
the electrode she's clear I'm like a
defibrillator yeah and defibrillators
back then that could have saved a cap
room not in the water that would kill
everybody no I mean you get em out of
the water
oh yeah and one such as after she let
him go after she let him go five seconds
later people show we need another ten
minutes in that movie just to make it
palpable it wouldn't have been the hit
the Caprio a dying man Caprio has to die
in a move like I think he dies like
every other movie you know what movie
it's not like a traditional romantic
movie but there is a romantic element to
it that always like it has this romantic
quality that always gets me was
bad like that's sort of like angsty
romantic we're like they do it is about
two dudes like getting together at the
end like it is kind of like a
Shakespeare comedy that way in which
they all end up together why are you
shaking I don't know he's shaking cos
you're nervous about your answer here
are you worried that we're not gonna
respond worried about this body are you
worried that I need and I gonna gang up
on you for me fine I need uh oh
one woman joins in on the you now chat
yeah how she loves John Lola horror it's
always about wrong I'm not jealous I'm
jealous reading this book you guys can't
come you can't mindful path to self
compassion yeah now I'm drinking people
do so you do when you're single Aloha
Marie loves me she puts an lol oh joy
exclamation mark heart hearts and the
eyes mean I love you to drag lol
whatever it's fine I get you just want
to be friends Wow
I thought we had something Lola Marie
Lola's what I called my grandma we
should drink more often on these lives
yeah we talked about nothing this is all
Wallace's all formulated water Shaun of
the Dead is technically a romantic
comedy with zombies it's not a dead a
great one dude I love them dude yeah
miss ex-lovers has a correct even
straight men like Greg sexually straight
men think I get laid all the time I
why you don't get laid all the time you
are the type of person that has to feel
something and like be all I've knitted I
don't need to be committed you totally
do I just can't [ __ ] a girl and let her
and then be like be going with you like
be gone with you but you don't have to
make it such a big deal I don't need to
make it it be someone just described you
on YouTube is looking quote
exceptionally [ __ ] tonight me yes oh
yeah yeah not me why do you look at me
why do i chammak anyone because I wanted
you to feel it you know I wanted to give
you that motivate how many people are on
YouTube a lot 67 people are watching I
know 462 I had a 460,000 subscribers 72
are watching that means wow like
negative 0.1% or watching this video
subscribers oh hello love
Marie says to be honest I've taken eater
over both of you all oh yeah good choice
yes choice we would make love all night
all right no Flores we're gonna guess
here we go here we go no honest all
right we got to go in a few minutes guys
yeah we can't keep this party train
rolling all night hi you no no no what's
up with your face where is the rest of
it can you show me your lips hey you are
oh what a handsome man you are you like
your lips Noah I can't touch me let's
let me handle this
I know how to deal with subscribers all
right especially the mail no
in the world hey hey I said I'd handle
this Noah I ask the question what's
hurry this is like the Ouija board one
question at a time
fine what's your favorite thing in the
world and you can't say me and my affair
thing in the world is like superheroes
geek that's what I and my favorite thing
in the world is superheroes I'm a geek
because I for a second I face its serial
killer who's your who's your favorite
who's your favorite superhero yeah fixed
you are
spider-man oh really right on yeah it's
like that word - web action do you think
that spider-man is actually homosexual
and that's why he can never make things
work with Mary Jane maybe Mary James the
homosexual that's why you can't make
things for him mm-hmm I do not was
relatively and you're really I would say
no what's your ethnicity who's your
favorite serial killer guys one question
at a time
I think we G more lychee beware the
Queen my ethnicity is um is Mexican and
my favorite serial killer is Jack the
Ripper oh yeah Jack the Ripper there's a
great serial killer juicy firm pal with
Johnny Depp the movie from Hell - Jack
the Ripper movie not good you should
watch it I know I haven't seen that one
yeah you should watch it if you're in
Jack the Ripper fan I've ever been
turned on at the thought of murdering a
girl no it's a good answer that we have
nothing in common now
you pass you pass this is the kind of
questions - cops'll ass we're not gonna
wiretap anymore what are you what are
you up to on a Valentine's Day evening
besides well gee I just saw you guys
were live and I'm just like yeah there's
nothing to do how old are you Noah
15 surprisingly I do I I think I look
look I look a lot younger no dude you
look like you're at least 17 sure when I
was 15 that's what I had my first love
I'll tell you guys your name and I'm not
one to ever speak about my personal this
girl was then Haley Janet Oh John Muir I
did she was a super hardcore Christian
she's now married and has a kid
she moved on do you have a girlfriend
Noah no no have you ever had a
girlfriend
nope well no I need to get him some
advice because I suck it I am NOT a good
person to give advice because I'm a
commitment-phobe
this girl's full of all kind of STDs I
am that's why it's the one thing I can
commit why because I'm not like your
average well here's what I can tell you
it will work for me when I was 15 you
see something happened along my 20s I
started caring about the way people feel
which has really cock-blocked me along
the way
I don't get leis I'm so concerned about
the outcome of a girls feel I need to
chill out right what I would say is you
see I feel like you got a sense of humor
are you funny you can see yourself funny
uh yeah actually all right all right
humor is the greatest aphrodisiac or do
you just want to [ __ ] intercourse when I
was legal this is small right not don't
you mention her a queen wait till
marriage in this house like truly I'm
asking legitimately are you just looking
to screw someone are you looking for a
relationship no I'm not
honestly you want a relationship that's
good and you know you just got you got
it finds that girl that is looking for
the same thing so let's create a URI as
most girls don't have STDs by that point
true also good yes so get to bang it as
soon as possible my friend
well not as soon as possible wait till
you're 18 like we owe this is no wait
until the right moment no you got it
you'll know the right moment because
you'll know the right mom just listen to
yourself when you're a little turned on
that's the best advice I have always
wear condoms yes and don't try too hard
don't worry condoms I said against the
cap always wear a hat I'll die no no
we're gonna have to leave you know uh
but I hope this serves you well in the
future you seem like a really sweet guy
Mexican serial killer Frey I hope
you find a relationship with a girl who
deserves you he doesn't just want a [ __ ]
which was what I was impressed by
because you know a lot of guys here
birdy demon is here this guy is the
perverted version of Matt Damon you guys
you guys will like make G the director G
dirty buried Amma we can't hear don't
know it's like freaking out over you're
freaking out are you freaking out it's
glitching okay oh he means do you love
you guys so much [ __ ] dirty birdie
Damon can you hear us
I can't even like I can't understand
what you're saying he's not like a
robotic wrong can you hear me now can
you uh can you um guess me and then
guess me back maybe try one more time
that's a major request he seems like a
great human being a thousand bar so give
him another shot okay sure how are the
people on you now they're pretty you to
be let's get a couple questions in while
we wait for him to come back
alright someone offered to smoke you out
hey who offer to smoke me out blunt man
there we go smoke this [ __ ] we gonna
smoke this Oh Jude they're doing a
genius silent Barbara yes dude [ __ ]
rad Kevin
Smith and Jason yeah dude Kevin Smith I
like that yet he seems like a cool dude
vodcasts that's very fascinating yeah
Lola Marie of course wants to know if
John is single yes why do you girls
always ask about Shawn you want to know
if he's single
yes does he have a big dick I don't know
is he good at sex
you might be a little self-conscious is
he kind yes there there's John tinder
profile waiting for the guys that's
games played frequently strong buddy
Greg lifts lots of heavy objects with
his bump
I took John to the gym yesterday [ __ ]
Adam workout his lower body no that's
not what I'm saying
wow you're really good at pumping where
a girl yeah a mess you bi me so bad you
know what dude whenever I've watched
like a porno with a girl with a strap-on
and she's having the cheese of like
wearing this gem like [ __ ] like a guy
yeah oh my very impressive yeah cuz
girls are not meant to move like that
I'm not meant to accomplish their
thrusting a dick in someone okay so very
impressive to you porn actresses out
there I'm sure a lot of you are watching
this live stream right now a couple of
people on YouTube think you've got a big
ass yes
Longman you could smoke out of my ass
you know jack price forgave a thousand
bars girls gone wild
that was the porno I grew up do it again
ah Jack price for that's for you my
friend
it's called nipple chill shoutouts Shawn
doesn't show a nipple
Johnny shall be grass distressing he was
fourth grade doesn't that stretch more
sighs now wait I saw in the sauna
yesterday
Brendan V loves me see the straight guys
love me solid straight boys all of the
straight guys want to have sex with Greg
all the straight guys want to do a
relationship stuff with Greg you know
because this is what we do on
Valentine's Day neither we were supposed
to pack what we know she said the word
came that hysterical someone thinks our
live stream is more fun than 50 shades
Doris yes which i think is a real
achievement who said that Maurice the
right amount of dirty
mariko true Mariko true said that where
we'll hold hands like this to really
mislead my audience
Fifty Shades yeah yeah yeah that's very
confusing very where's my speech where
does my dick and then the rest of you
begin whoa whoa I I didn't want to come
off my hand I jerked off the mic is
thick af guys guys I just I just find
you
have-have actually I just fine touch me
with it once Greg is not I don't think
Greg let's eat my might full penis
Lola Maurice jealous gosh oh it just
follows Shawn on Instagram and DM him
dude DM for the deep us director of
photography walls guys we're gonna do
time if you ask me oh we're not doing it
oh yeah we're just two men it was a
really a fancy once I used to fantasize
about that it 12 court says wasn't that
chick with Tyrone do she was never with
Tyrone me Tyrone's are pathological
Tyrone is a liar he's a jerk and he
makes all his reaction young gusto says
I remember back when you guys at da sums
and seven when rounded you out oh yeah 7
where those in the spider-man channel
yeah that's the Salamanders Sally was on
the channel I haven't mentioned her in a
long time Sally was like a great friend
of mine but we haven't really connected
in a long time to change yeah she was
cool cooling cute young guy still thinks
that on would dominate you Tyrone can't
fight I can fight no you wouldn't last
one guys stick look as much as that
makes centimeter
did you know like a kung-fu move with
the proper
vertical
the proper term is if you do this kind
of punch yeah
fasten up to the chest man so that to
the chest
this is not how strong they are that's
enough horse because this need of a
punch and a kick you can create enough
creep pounds of damage so many cubic
feet of damage hey guys you know I see
John and Greg make up who we started the
real HX we were just we're all about
movie reviews and then we started doing
these reactions you know why the
reactions start everyone always asked
where the reactions start from where did
it start I didn't call you that's coming
right now
[Music]
John this little Murray chick is low
every how old are you before I make a
dirty comment how are you Oh Murray hey
Lola Murray why don't you give him a
guest he's 22 okay would you not
somebody just said that they would
totally fall asleep if you were like
giving them a scalp massage so if you
were playing with their hair they for me
listen II guys I'm a very good scalp
they want to know if you're Italian wait
I was telling a story
sorry my shoulders a little bit yeah
thank you
[Music]
you know I'm not naked that's it someone
wants you to hide around the start of
podcasts with the thing with Tyrone
talking about you guys would just talk
about like like the pretty side of the
reactor world I just complain about yeah
we're great it was that was really
serious time with our jobs man man
cheetah boats no hate everything
talked about its it was make fun of
reaction channels for a while where do
reactions start from all right so you
guys before there was Tyra before there
was me there was a man named Gator
Mardan and he did these reactions you
know my thought was what who the [ __ ] is
watching these videos who's gonna sit
here and watch these people and then hi
hi I didn't laugh you and I was like
holy [ __ ] watching so people are like
reactions are some of the easiest form
you'll never hear me step out and go
that's not true
I'm well aware that they're easy to do
what I will say is at least for sure
John and I toid grandpa John and I John
I really went out of a way to provide
thorough trailer reviews at least I know
when we feel like YouTube video
reactions we kind of just stand like
weird discussions we don't really come
up with like crazy intellectual talks
but when it came to the movie talks
that's when John and I really went out
of our way dude jimmies steven-thomas a
thousand bars
has been around since the beginning
Stevens is a [ __ ] legend no you guys
aren't Stan G Steve's been around for a
very long time these guys that's what
bars are out [ __ ] now guys my last
line this apartment you know I'm just
really nice my neighbors you know what
they're moving to so it doesn't matter
yeah sure I'm just trying to make a
point like they're not gonna be here
forever this is not like a thing that's
gonna just stay the way it is people are
gonna just move and that's part of life
and you had a great experience with them
and they're gonna be your friends
forever no yes Joseph so why don't you
make thumbnails we do make thumbnails if
you look at our movie reviews or movie
news and stuff we go out of our way to
make thumbnail yeah those are all your
racket record reaction
Brendan V I'm gonna tell you right now
whoa stop donating you weren't doing no
no what have we done to earn these
donations we've done nothing to earn
these donations and you guys keep
donating your eggs more fun when he's
not sober that's why I do my reality I
would be offended but I'm like
everyone's more fun when they're not
I mean as long as they're not chaos mage
wants to know how many times you jerked
it to gal gadot's Wonder Woman who that
was gal Oh
Gallagher down I've never jerked a gal
gadot she's too skinny for me I like bet
the meat then on my buns hugs to Brazil
thank you guys
Thank You Paolo guys Ben Ito rod $1.99
with your movie sucks
what was her movie sucks I guess back in
the chair and he is the best wingman
very great wingman strewth someone just
described us as Where's Waldo the weed
comic and a random [ __ ] groupie yes guys
which I am the random [ __ ] girl which
superhero would know I am don't take
that away from you it's superhero would
we be who would John be hello to you're
never here
Jenny's Jambi who wouldn't need a
complete ass time I've been drunk way
Morrison's in these going too much all
right guys I'm gonna focus up this is
what every drunk guy does huh I'm not
drunk
what do you think of Ben Affleck leaving
the family is he leaving the vampire or
is that just a rumor I heard that was a
rumor
no what Tyrone did was Ben after leaving
the Batman put a question mark assault
clickbait it's totally an article I
watched the video did you watch the
video is the video primarily Tyrone
reading the article or is it him
primarily giving opinions on reading the
article and then talking about it how
long did you talk about it like a minute
shorter than the time it's like a man
who thinks beautiful who thinks someone
thinks I would be why is no
Oh [ __ ] Greg because he's beautiful
two bars are coming
you heard that compliments to John this
is a bear you need to give hello to the
Philippines has made hey pics for Batman
directors John Gotti this is your poster
this is film reel from The Dark Knight
these are posters from The Dark Knight
no Charlie for your friend years when I
get married
aka something oh I'm gonna tell you guys
John's gonna be my best mate Lola Marie
gave me a compliment to take my shirt
off whenever I do a live stream you know
I'm building muscle Megan Fox I gotta be
like Tyrone back together
just like every girl I'm not drunk
you're all drunk you see this is what
happens when you get
all right all right guys don't worry I'm
not drunk we're good
pretty good guys don't ever use this
footage in a compilation for it let's
get it let's go to Western bacon
cheeseburger Ryoga David Hasselhoff's
know that you're a masterpiece of a man
look at that bad said that's of John or
every second we look like the kids in
high school who would sit with the
alternative veggies
yes you know we are those [ __ ] sheep
John tends to get compliments on his
personality masterkey and his initials
well you are a masterpiece are you
decent Greg please don't [ __ ] that I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get so naked
send me your DM on Instagram you're
getting a big thick guys you should end
this and go the thing yeah that sounds
like a good plan with listen guys we're
gonna start going to okay somebody wants
you to pull your pants down but I don't
I'm not I'm not gonna get my pants off
unless the girl is question if a girl
doesn't request it then I'm not gonna do
it
I'll give you money for the job guys why
don't you like settle on cruising
altitude for a minute why did you do
Leonardo a city's waiting for Jon to
side with the iron before reaching our
technology is going into the red shift
any did we get 1200 bars dude I think we
got over 200 bars and be pretty don't
talk
can pov
let me read you guys a set Greg you got
a don't personality I don't think your
channel look without your personality
and else's job but it seems you know
oblong videos listen can't be AV this
channel will be taken over by none other
than idubbbz idubbbz has proven that he
loves reaction channels I just got out
of his way to give shoutouts to my
channel and other reaction channels I
does I dub stinks reaction channels are
the best great Andrei has said he would
only give up his channel if he could
take over my channel and do reactions
you know what branded vigils they they
have a thing and it is to talk about it
is nothing personal guys even though
even though 90 percent 90 to 95 percent
of the reactions we do we have
authorized permission to do reactions
from them last week
let's begin certainly in terms of the
youtubers yes was it King drink waves
trailers you never know sometimes we're
cool sometimes the studio send you on
exploited them are trying to interact as
well Gregory good way if you do reaction
channel if you do reactions to well I
gotta hit accept your own triggers like
wait what if you shout me out
riah I mean Greg I will blow you like
lobster I just shouted you out you need
to blow Greg hard okay
with that [ __ ] we're never in a
thousand I'm so sorry
the muslim man doesn't affect you even
if I was
guys listen if you want to know about
reaction channels it becomes these
trailers and stuff most of the time
studios give us the trailers in advance
I'm telling you that's a real thing you
don't have to explain your yes I know
you're [ __ ] dumb because like there
are lots of people who are interested in
reaction channels and that is a thing
and it's never gonna go away no matter
what any [ __ ] other user says about
that's nicely the fine brothers died out
years ago they tried to [ __ ] know but
they tried to [ __ ] legs this is
called medical marijuana so so horny
here oh so horny for you she's rubbing
her clitoris to this shawl looking it
right now okay John is there anybody to
guess no why are you here Jimmy all
denied you are [ __ ] the bomb dig yes
Pakistan vs. Gator Oh Jimmy James what's
up my friend no he looks like Harry
Potter not that other than you think
everybody with glasses looks like Harry
Potter
no you don't look like Harry Potter you
look like your face so high I
I used to get that all the time as a kid
Jimmy what what where do you live
Ohio Ohio
what part yeah oh you're drinking to
look at you
John has a lot of are you drinking by
yourself do you not drinking by yourself
anymore that's right all the night with
Greg John Jimmy do you do you watch your
Jimmy Stephens
do your Jimmy Stephens out even if I was
sober right now you're Jimmy Stephens
I've never seen your [ __ ] face this
guy's always is day one some guys so
worried I'm drunk
all right Jewish siegen's dude you've
been around since the beginning you're
like one of the og subscribers holy [ __ ]
this is what you look like
[ __ ] subscribers I really and he
notices do you see this [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] I think I love my subscribers to
much for Jimmy [ __ ] it Jimmy's been
around since like like forever Jimmy
would it would tell me who you are my
friend guys quiet Jimmy's talking Jimmy
who are you tell me about you
24:22 good-paying job
I guess what do you do for a living what
housework okay dare you interested in
film or something like that
oh yeah I have a massive collection well
okay maybe not massive but but you're
from you're from Ohio John has a lot of
family in Ohio dude I'm telling you
right now if your [ __ ] ass ever
comes to California you were more than
welcome to come on the channel or we
wound up in Ohio for some reason we're
never going what's there to do on my own
so Jimmy really you man what's your
favorite video on their channel what I
like mm tell me Oh too many to name
yeah let's go with that Oh Jimmy when
did you subscribe to our channel a few
years ago I don't remember this guy
commenting booth at least before we were
at like 30 K subs yes Wow hey wait
probably way less than that actually
yeah I think so are you uh are you an
only child Jimmy no I got two older
sisters are they hot like you oh Christ
look gonna hook up look at hook over
your sister right he could be your
brother they're both married sorry both
married are they happily married Jimmy
absolutely [ __ ] do they have kids Jimmy
yes
[Applause]
amazing nephews and a wonderful niece
somebody on our YouTube stream wants to
know what your favorite Tarantino movie
probably inglorious basterds no choice
any any charity no choice is a good
choice Brutus that's the thing about it
Jimmy it's so good to see your face man
that's good to meet you you have no idea
man I have no idea what you look like
how much do you love this right now guys
if you were in person and you wanted to
see my left testicle I would show you
both Oh left and the right side yeah
he wouldn't show you dick though he
would just show you his his sack with
both testicles inside like so cool to
like connect cabrona
Greg loves Corona you guys are the same
tasting I do look good
Jimmy man you've got [ __ ] mad well
that's in the guest you Jimmy next time
we're on you now make sure the guest
jack is we're gonna guest shot you
John's lonely on Valentine's Day so we
gotta talk about it Lola chick a
question Jimmy or anything you want to
say cuz you deserve the time what's up
questions don't come to mind why do you
want to say that means we got yeah what
do you want to say to them we are sir
I'm pretty sure sometimes when you go on
you now
I'm at work so I that's not a guarantee
that I'd be able to join it but I
usually going you doubt like after 7
p.m. my time Pacific Standard Time
well Jimmy thank you so much for coming
on and show me - I love your Jimmy
you've been around so you are ever owed
you reject I don't meet too many subs
that are like been around
forever wait wait before you drop him
out of the you now sets Jim is serious
Stieg ins your [ __ ] man I love
you jerk-off all right how's it going
how's your Valentine's Day so I'm trying
to like raise the volume like this this
is a clunky process we've also got a
dance happening in the background lala
land is happening in the bag is a
romantic evening with the work go
tell us how sexy evening John how are
you as your Valentine's Day going where
are you going you look like you're
traveling right now are you going
someplace dark Oh like a root cellar
it's actually exactly where I'm going so
great you knew that as you can see lots
of alcohol we might get in a car at some
point soon that's a scary prospect none
of us have any place to be on
Valentine's Day and so good to see you
it's good to speak to you in person it's
hard to hearing you but we're making do
John sharp it's going great
it's going great we're already moving in
together it's fine yeah it's a good time
right wait how do you ask your questions
to make sure she you can meet up hey
where are you from Lola a state location
hmm nowhere near y'all [ __ ] where
Antarctica will drive alas dry he will
[ __ ] he west from Texas Waco
I'm Dallas we can make this happen John
hold on
Amarillo Dallas Dallas Dallas don't
please don't break that don't break your
guitar be an imbecile a little bit when
you're drunk
give me my guitar I'm gonna serenade you
right now give it what do you want for
Valentine's Day what's your Valentine's
Day wish I don't have one you don't have
one I spent a Valentine's Day with my
life so I'm good all right hey that's
great you win
you've won how old are you how old are
you 22 22 and you're already content
it's good I'm glad to hear that you got
to share with us the secret what's your
favorite motion picture
[Music]
but it's my favorite the holiday okay
shots a romantic movie black isn't it
yep he is that he is and hans zimmer did
the school sorry I have a song from that
soundtrack it's great come on awkward at
least for me what's awkward for you
this experience is awkward okay well how
do we make it more awkward alright wait
sorry there is so much chaos going on in
the next room I don't know what to do
you dropped me you want dollar for this
I can't just abandon you in a spooky
cellar
haven't you seen horror cinema yeah nope
but then like people will get offended
so I'm not gonna make it oh I'm so I
understand thank you
listen this has been a lovely
conversation thank you for letting me
shatter all illusions about you know the
appeal of me and stay classy no class is
great if you want to have Crowley only
be a [ __ ] if you want to do you know I'm
joking all right goodbye lolly
beautiful and John Bazaar appreciate
your the way I do goodbye Lola you're so
sexy and horrible all right guys listen
thanks to all you guys who donated
you're all beautiful mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] happy Valentine's Day if you're
alone on Valentine's Day with us mother
[ __ ] tonight so shout out to all you
[ __ ] and goodbye